the idea of jury nullification has been
around since this country had juries the
idea is pretty simple juries can vote to
acquit defendants even when the
government proves its case Beyond a
reasonable doubt if you serve on a jury
and you listen to all the evidence and
you can still vote not guilty and you
can walk right out of the courthouse and
tell everyone that the guy did it but
you didn't care maybe you didn't like
the law maybe you didn't like the
prosecutor maybe you were just having a
bad day whatever it is it's your right
to vote to acquit the defendant will
walk and the judge and the government
can't do anything about it in the
history of this country jury
nullification has been especially
prominent in periods of open race hatred
during the 19th century juries often
refuse to convict people who were
accused of of helping Escape slaves in
violation of the Fugitive Slave Act and
later in the Civil Rights area era some
all-white juries would acquit people
clearly committed acts of violence
against blacks so there are clearly good
uses of jury nullification and there are
bad uses of it as you would expect
but on balance this is a feature not a
bug of our Judicial System that's the
conventional wisdom anyway
what's not conventional wisdom because
no one's talking about it even on the
right
is that jury nullification is making a
major comeback right now and this is not
the jury nullification that Supreme
Court Justices like John Jay endorsed
back in the day I'm talking about a
return of the Civil Rights era of jury
nullification where jury is egged on by
prosecutors in some cases refused to
punish racist criminals who are
obviously guilty
only this time the criminals are not
white they're black this is widespread
at the moment in this country it is
impossible to deny we have fully
imported South African style juries
where race and cast matters more than
the facts of the case
I'm going to start with one of the most
egregious recent examples of the jury
nullification that I'm talking about
this is a case involving the brutal
killing of a 17 year old white high
school student in Akron Ohio named Ethan
Lyman now last summer Ethan liming and
his friends decided to do some stupid
Tick-Tock challenge where they take a
toy gel gun and fire it at random people
and here's the police chief in Akron
explaining what the gun looks like and
what it does watch
yet so the description of this
toy and it's targeted for ages 14 and up
is that you take these little beads
you soak them in water this is my
understanding of it you soak it in water
and then you load
this
what they describe as a toy gun
and it shoots these water beads
at people or or objects whatever the
target is when it impacts the target it
like a water balloon it explodes
and then the person is doused with water
okay it's important to see what those
guns look like because that is obviously
a toy water gun it's very clearly not a
real gun
and so Ethan lyming and his friends
armed with this toy water gun drove
around and then they came across several
young black men ages 19 to 21 who are
playing basketball in a parking lot near
LeBron James's I promise school and
liming's Friends made the very dumb
decision to shoot the water pellets at
these black men with the toy gun
now evidence of trial which includes
surveillance footage shows that the
black men initially ran away thinking
that they were under attack
but then
probably when they realize what was
actually happening that they weren't in
any the you know their their lives were
not in jeopardy they turned back and
they charged at the car that liming was
in there was testimony that liming fired
some water pellets at the men who were
now running at him the key Point here is
that this was not a split second thing
where the black men attacked in
self-defense thinking the gun was real
they pursued liming to get back at him
for his prank
what happened next is that Ethan lyming
died a horrible death when police
arrived they found blood coming from
liming's mouth ears and nose
he hadn't simply been punched in the
face and given a black eye although
that's true as well he had been stumped
he had a broken collarbone he had
multiple blunt force injuries all over
his body the coroner noted that there
was a shoe print on his chest now think
about the amount of force
choir to leave a shoe print on someone's
chest
think about the savagery involved in
that
and trial the defense argue that Ethan
lyman's killers were in fear for their
life because of the toy gun
they weren't mad that they'd been
pranked instead they were deathly afraid
of the water gun so so they went to town
is that plausible well initially
prosecutors didn't think so that's why
they brought murder charges against the
men responsible for this killing which
seems obviously appropriate
given the facts of the case
and given that those facts simply don't
support a self-defense claim again they
pursued him they assaulted him and they
stomped on him while he was on the
ground it was three against one
and after killing him they stole his car
so even if we were to accept the
outlandish idea that they ran after this
guy still thinking that he was a crazed
shooter with a real gun that just so
happened to look like a plastic toy gun
well by the time they were stomping him
to death on the ground it would have
been exceedingly clear to everybody
involved that he was not a threat
also keep in mind that at least one of
the three assailants had been hit in the
face with the water pellet and you know
that couldn't have felt very good but it
does mean that they obviously knew that
it was a toy gun
their lives were not in danger
they stomped him to death and they stole
his car because they were angry
and and uh stopping someone to death and
killing them because you're mad that's
not a legitimate excuse at least it's
not supposed to be in a civilized
society
so this was murder obviously but the
murder charges didn't last long watch
police originally charged DeSean
Stafford his brother Tyler and their
cousin Donovan Jones with murder but in
July a grand jury indicted them on
lesser charges liming blames The Summit
County prosecutor's office for that
decision he doesn't believe all of the
facts were presented Akron Police said
back in June race was not a factor in
The Killing there is nothing that we
have in our possession right now any
information at all indicating that race
played a role in this homicide
nothing
you get the idea a couple things about
this first of all if the prosecutors had
wanted the grand jury to indict on
murder charges they could have done that
that's not really in dispute especially
after the Trump prosecutions where the
grand jury wanted to indict everyone's
ever talked to Trump and uh and they did
so everyone knows how grand juries work
in this country you know the saying
about a grand jury could indict a ham
sandwich because you can the prosecutors
could get anybody indicted with the
grand with it by a grand jury there's no
defense counsel present prosecutors can
basically say whatever they want to the
grand jury and they can indict anyone
for any crime so why didn't prosecutors
want murder charges here why did they
effectively downgrade to a much less
serious offense which is involuntary
manslaughter
liming's father spoke to local media
about the prosecutor's decision and he
says that at least one prosecutor said
that his son got what he deserved in the
form of hood Justice watch between the
detectives and the prosecutors described
that Prosecutor's meeting as being very
contentious some of the prosecutors
wanting felonious assault charges and
murder charges others basically wanting
no charges at all with one of the
prosecutors saying that Ethan received
Hood Justice which was a new term to me
I was unfamiliar with that terminology
Hood Justice
and that I guess implying that Ethan got
what he deserved
Hood Justice that's from a prosecutor
now you can believe what liming's father
says or you can choose not to believe it
whatever the case it's objectively true
that involuntary manslaughter is an
absurdly lenient charge when you Pummel
someone on the ground after he fired a
water gun at you
involuntary manslaughter makes sense
when you're speeding and you hit
somebody in a crosswalk
you know but when you're standing over
somebody with a child's toy causing
blood to come out of every orifice of
his body
you're probably committing a voluntary
act called Murder
at the very least you think that it'd be
up to a jury to decide whether it's
murder or not but prosecutors in Akron
didn't see it that way so the murder
charge was off the table and just by
doing that just by removing the prospect
of murder from the case prosecutors sent
a very clear signal to jurors and the
signal is that this was all an accident
at worst
nobody really intended anyone to die
and just to reiterate that point the
prosecutors offered jurors another
option which is that they could also
convict the thugs of assault
which is interesting so you could get a
victim of assaulting someone until they
die
but then not convict them of the actual
murder or manslaughter
well it doesn't make any sense but lo
and behold that's exactly what happened
this week Ethan lyman's Killers got off
with a with a conviction for assault
that's it they were acquitted of
involuntary manslaughter it's as if they
just got into a nasty bar fight or
something
they stomped somebody to death
and all they're getting is an assault
charge conviction rather
so they'll almost certainly be out of
jail within two years if not sooner
this is jury nullification encouraged by
prosecutors there's no other term that
you can use to describe this and it's
it's not just happening in Akron
consider that just a few weeks ago a
jury found that a member of a black
nationalist militia named othell Wallace
had committed manslaughter instead of
murder after he shot a police officer to
death on camera
Wallace shot this officer named Jason
Raynor in the head this was an
unprovoked murder random was responding
to a call of suspicious activity in an
apartment complex
and Wallace killed him again there's no
doubt about that the murder was caught
on body him otha Wallace is not simply a
member of a black nationalist black
supremacist group after executing Jason
Raynor Wallace boasted on Instagram
about putting pigs in their place
he fled to Georgia where his black
nationalist group called nfac for not
effing around Coalition helped him hide
Wallace also cut his dreadlocks to hide
his appearance
and all this came out in trial watch
and then you say all these crackers and
the power I'm speaking to them yeah but
he also said something about me getting
banned is Instagram a bunch of practice
I'm not sure if it is a law enforcement
officers no sir no sir okay well you
refers to law enforcement as a case
don't you no sir in fact after you
killed officer Vayner or shot him you
went on Instagram and you posted that I
I'm not gonna let these pigs do anything
to me correct
I said I said yes I did refer to as pigs
but when I see a word pigs I'm not
specifically always talking about police
officers I'm talking about people who
don't see me as human okay so when you
shout officer radar you refer to him as
a pig and all the other people as pigs
the officers correct no not just all not
just when I said it again I'm referring
to people who don't see me as human sure
oh yeah well so he shot the police
officer and killed him and then talked
about uh pigs but he wasn't talking
about police officers I mean you can't
imagine can you imagine that going the
other way somebody uh kills uh murder is
a black man and then later uh posts on
social media using the n-word and then
he's asked about it said well yeah it
was so unrelated I didn't say N word I
mean that guy could have been referring
to anybody this wasn't really race based
necessarily
like there's no way that argument would
be bought in court but after that
testimony that you just saw after
shooting a police officer in the face
and killing him otha Wallace was
convicted of manslaughter not murder
which carries a possible death sentence
manslaughter the local sheriff said that
he was quote that he never quote he he
never he'd never been more disgusted by
a verdict in his entire career and you
can see why Vladimir Putin called the US
Dollars drop in dominance objective and
irreversible as Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa formally agreed
to use local currencies in trade instead
of the US dollar as demand for the
dollar weakens the buying power of the
dollar weakens and that is why Birch
gold is busier than ever investors and
Savers are looking to harness the power
of physical gold held in a tax sheltered
IRA and you can too you could protect
your IRA or 401K by diversifying with
gold from Birch gold as the US dollar
continues to receive pressure from
foreign countries digital currency and
central banks arm yourself with
information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text Walsh to 989898 and they'll
send you a free info kit on gold with an
A plus rating with a Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews I trust
Birch gold to help you diversify into
gold if a central bank digital currency
ever becomes a reality it'll be nice to
have some gold to depend on again text
Walsh to 989898
again this is not simply jury
nullification this is race-based during
the obligation that prosecutors are
encouraging
in some cases they're not even leaving
it to the juries they're offering
murderers really attractive plea deals
to short-circuit the whole trial process
altogether remember the 41 year old guy
in North Dakota named Shannon Brandt he
confessed to killing Kaylor Ellingson
who was a teenager and why did he do
that well Brandt was drunk and he
assumed that that when Ellingson was on
the phone with his mom that he was
really communicating with some sort of
Maga Republican militia so Brandt ran
Ellingson over with his Ford Explorer
killed him and then he fled the scene
and that's murder but Shannon Brandt
wasn't charged with murder instead he
was hit with manslaughter charges
instead
prosecutors offered him those charges
part of the plea deal which of course he
accepted and there are many more
examples like this there's the case of
James McGee who used a metal pipe to
bludgeon a 62 year old cab driver named
Arif Muhammad qasim to death back in
2019 he literally beat his brains out
San Francisco's D.A at the time let
McGee plead to involuntary manslaughter
in the name of equity after beating
someone to death with a lead pipe
the same thing happened to the killer of
Seth Smith a Berkeley student who was
shot in the back of the head at
point-blank range by a lifelong criminal
named Tony Walker and the moment that
homicide detectives reached out to
Walker he explained that he was he was
frustrated that they cared about Smith's
death to begin with he said quote
a white kid gets killed in the and the
damn whole world stops F that white
mother effort
that's what he said to the cops
how do prosecutors respond well they
offered Tony Walker a plea of
manslaughter
that's despite the fact that a probation
officer determined that quote the
defendant has demonstrated that he is a
danger to the community and needs to be
separated for the community's protection
the defendant has established an
entrenched pattern of criminal conduct
that probation prison and parole have
been unable to eradicate
nevertheless Tony Walker was not brought
up on hate crime charges or thrown in
prison for life as he would be if he
were white this was not a repeat of the
Ahmad Arbury case with the races reverse
instead prosecutors let Tony Walker take
a manslaughter plea and for good measure
lawmakers in Berkeley later prevented
police from running most parole
researches like the one that led cops to
apprehend Walker in the first place and
we can go on and on listing examples but
there's one more very recent one that we
need to fit in here a man named Calvin
ushry
uh he brutally assaulted pistol-whipped
and robbed a jewelry store owner and the
whole thing was caught on camera plan
his day
but guess what happened at trial watch
new at 11 tonight a jury could not reach
a verdict in a brutal attack and robbery
of a Wilmington jewelry store owner
Calvary nashary was on trial for various
charges including robbery and assault
after two days of deliberations a
mistrial was declared this surveillance
video was shown during the trial coming
up right here prosecutors argued usheri
violently attacked the owner of Solid
Gold Jewelers back in September of last
year the owner was so badly beaten he
underwent months of Rehabilitation
prosecutors planned to retry the case
the jury couldn't reach a verdict usheri
is on video walking into a jewelry store
grabbing the store owner pistol whipping
him stomping on his head and beating him
with a hammer before walking off with a
hundred thousand dollars worth of stolen
merchandise he was he was charged with
assault and robbery because you know you
can see him on camera assaulting and
robbing someone
but the jury was deadlocked
they couldn't figure out they looked at
that video said I don't know what's
happening there who knows it's
impossible to tell
now we all know why it was deadlocked
there were members of that jury who
didn't want to convict a black man no
matter how obviously guilty he was
that's what happened and we all know it
and this is what's been happening in
courtrooms all over the country without
any Fanfare whatsoever
the left has targeted conservatives
whether they're politicians or
pro-lifers or random people posting
memes that offend Hillary Clinton
everybody knows that but at the same
time all over the country the primary
voting blocks of the democratic party
are committing the most heinous crimes
imaginable including murder
only for prosecutors and juries to let
them off the hook
they're doing it deliberately
and in the process they have established
a true two-tier justice system a
hierarchy where the severity of a crime
is judged based on the demographics of
those involved
and the lives of victims are ranked
based on their race and their politics
sadly for the family of Ethan lyming
he falls at the bottom of that totem
pole
which means that there will be no
justice for him
because we are no longer a country that
believes in Justice
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed